[Musique]
monsieur ses tripes
30-30
sait pas comment des petits bouts c'est
pas des tripotées des tripes à eux et
des tripes à la mode de caen this is a
commandé un mois je sais pas pourquoi
mais j'ai pas commander pourquoi
voulez-vous avoir écouté moi je fais ça
moi on me demande je vois la regarder oh
[ __ ] tu sais déjà ce genre de sa garde
et c'est un coach
pas des tripes non non non mais je vois
pas qui sait aucun doute écouté
les deux camps
ah ouais
en scooter
non non je rigole pas bon ça j'aime pas
ça et puis regardez la tronche que ça
j'ai même pensé à cause de la grippe
c'est de la triche de [ __ ] de jo
mais regardez le pardon tu obligé de
vous les compter un nombre de noms
commencent à annoncer pour moi j'ai une
bosse sur wii
vous insistez pas si tout ce que je peux
vous demander pourquoi c'était moi
j'arrive de bosser non vous assistez
passé pour moi
mais c'est bien votre adresse
attention c'est show you all alors au
nom regarder ce mal est fait je les
revendre je vais les revendre 1 c'est
pas grave
d'un côté moi ça madame goûtez-moi ça
goûtez moi ça goûtez moi ça
goûte à goûte et goûter
alors comment elle son temps mais j'ai
rien demandé j'ai petites conneries
comme ça vous êtes ça à faire emmerder
nous c'est pas moi vous si vous avez
commandé des tripes le met dans la boîte
aux lettres
encore ici j'entends pas
je les met dans la boîte aux lettres
ok ok j'y vais j'y vais
pas sandra seul c'est bien ça voilà
[Applaudissements]
regardez pardon pardon allez ça va
[Musique]